how's it going man
my name is back welcome back to another
episode of the coyote I know a thing
like that
all right oh we're gonna go to the staff
room it's over here I checked it out I
didn't airway I just had an intuition
that was gonna be there so yeah the door
is now unlocked so is your mum's mr.
Shack
are they are doing here with lamp are
you a time well I think the lamp in this
challenge
what the hell
Oh bad Oh No this is not funny
hello is it hot in here
I don't mr. Sherr are you crying
you think your [ __ ] cries like a girl
too
come on mr. Schad it's not that bad I'm
sorry I love to follow yours as much L
love you oh I press it for me I used to
be you shouldn't have I need to use my
drugs or something
I think check that [ __ ] off see that
Thank You mr. chair I'll see you later
all right so now I don't what the hell
is this by the way stone played left all
looks like all right Shh right whoa back
off the bird [ __ ] no one [ __ ] Birds
these days you know that no one no one
okay your mom last night I saw her you
think you can scare me ha ha ha no
no just don't try it don't try it
all right so let's go outside and play
come on squeeze through like a box can't
jump over what's the point of teasing me
with treason
there's no oh oh hello hello mrs. stone
Hafner oh oh you your bird [ __ ]
why'd I tell you about hugging the walls
he's merging I know that we're working
with the wall
alright so drop them like I mean there
we go and then combine or less support
us should we go back or should we take
another ride no why do I need a gun
[Music]
all right Oh what the hell I won't budge
that's a problem all right I think we
need to go back whoa the ladder come on
oh okay I go here I get it it's no
problem hey that's a problem can I go
here I lock the latch I don't even know
what a latches but I unlocked it all
right so I guess this is a number five
one one six seven three whatever let's
go and dial the number upstairs oh I saw
you your little bird [ __ ] back off I
don't have a lot of have our ammo for
that matter hate those birds what is
this
but I'm tensed ha ha ha ha
this is wallet okay I don't trust this
at our not one bet
I need that [ __ ] right now
let's drop this for a quote I like [ __ ]
you drop beautifully all right so let's
inject ourselves we have a lot of health
less health now ever since that [ __ ]
doctor shot to me I don't know why I do
that
where'd it go why did it go where did it
go oh oh I just flew off didn't it well
that's a problem I guess I got a [ __ ] at
least that quick so like two seconds ago
so that's all right I guess I know
you're gonna be there I know you're
gonna be there I am fine I am fine I am
fine
there you go whoa look at my Hale good
foot all right
ah Dom this is so big it makes just
sexting okay so we can't drop the I want
that serene I want it I want it on my
naked butt what what is that
why come on serene don't don't don't
fight it
don't fight it serene that it says I
need you to
[ __ ] it let's go all right so let's dial
the number here other defiled it I
should write a darkest you know five one
one
seven
three nine seven and then nine again I
think I am not quite sure but Lestrade
all right five one one seven three nine
it's not doing anything how what good
cutting scary
it says Oprah
what the hell she naked what is he doing
Oprah
what is his nonsense Oprah nine seven
one nine nine seven one nine nine Ohio
nine seven one nine nine seven one nine
nine ten nine one nine seven one nine
nine seven one nine nine seven one nine
two thousand two nine goddamn it one
seven all right it's upstairs so there's
no more girls up there ah don't trap and
grace alright let's just save here like
about now why Oprah would show me a
number nine seven one nine is it right I
mean of course it's obvious I mean four
digits like that's difficult oh oh no oh
no this is a boss time fight I think
they wouldn't give me these stuff by the
way [ __ ] me I'm screwed can I drop this
now or what I think we can drop you we
don't need you go ahead and do stuff
don't care about you I never cared about
you you know everyone in school talks
[ __ ] about you you know huh nobody loves
he likes you for that matter
you know that [ __ ] you know that all
right bring it whoever you are
bring of you whoever you are watch it
oh oh oh yo ho yo ho oh ho all right I
don't know I
wait is he you are dead mister dr. Pham
I am oh I got your head buddy
I am Hey aw come in show me your titties
and head I mean I am I am I am oh I am
oh come in bam oh bam by Auto reload
[Music]
yes
han you're busy a little prokhor uh
Simon so I know he was in look at his
face good to know what
when you ask Christ all right members I
like his moustache
why I don't know all right I just wanted
to
I don't like Facebook that's for shizzle
all right that's gay that's so gay okay
that's right I'm totally taking your Oh
Simon chill pill she'll pay Simon I know
you're angry but Jesus peanut alright
chapter seven [ __ ] what is that
inventory is full let's drop this one
water side a p3t soaker taking that [ __ ]
all right so we got a bloody key and
then I guess we go back I don't know
like I go back we don't even need it
alright let's save here whoa laughter
you return oh I missed you too lantern
are you being a good boy haven't you I'm
saying goodbye to you you little [ __ ] I
said goodbye it's not mean I pick you up
but frickin noise outside alright come
here come here lantern you and me again
together for can the birds just shut up
I guess I have to go outside now or
something I don't know down here I think
huh and it's getting beautiful outside
find your way home religion and lovely
see you later mental hospital hello
trees hello everyone
okay home sweet home
this is my crib so this is where I hang
out this is my sink
pretty sweet sink if I am I say to
myself this is my card where I shot but
revolved around that there no it's not
alright so this is my room
listen to out I'm tea I'm style you know
you know
I'm making that noise alright this is my
backyard got all my cards hiding beneath
the house and stuff so you know
alright I'm just squeeze through here
cuz I'm pretty fat and are we going back
this is where I went in the beginning so
a lot more comfortable in the likeness I
must say so there should be a door here
yeah alright Kristen is why the heck
would you go here if Oh like a dance
beautiful what's going on here it's not
a boat
hey are we going a boat ride this like
an afraid of monsters
oh no it's Loch Ness here I'm on a boat
I bought a boat everybody look at me cuz
I'm sailing known about or oh there's
suddenly both songs I don't even know
where to begin
nice music clearly no way faster you
little [ __ ]
that's right Simon faster faster
now I said an open course for the virgin
see I've got to be three faster you
little [ __ ] sit down boom I'm doing the
boom boom boom boom boom well that's a
pattern
[ __ ] you slow [ __ ] no I hate you oh
you're stopping oh no no no no no don't
you stop on my watch
it's no rest I don't care I've been one
[ __ ] minute pretty cool stuff here
I liked it's actually quite unbelievable
this is a half-life you know cuz
come on Simon come on is that all you
got
you're a big person aren't you you're
just one big vagina it's a plot twist
and I saw through it doesn't done for
the virgin see I've got to be free free
to face a life that's appear to me I'm
bored on the captain on the captain sign
when you're a [ __ ] so climb aboard we
search for tomorrow on every show and
I'll try Oh Lord I'll try
bam bam bam Babineaux Hey Humphry top
all right so let me show my second house
got pretty sweet houses here you know
got my walls pretty expensive wallpaper
that's my door that's my spare door cuz
you know I don't need more than one I
need one more than one oh no oh no no no
I did not know it but all I know we
gotta be together again I just know it I
did sar lantern but I don't really need
you cuz it's been you know not dark
anymore made by Thomas oh I missed you
did you miss me - I'm what are you doing
alright take an energy like favorite
cheese you enjoyed subscribe because to
becoming a bro today and I'll see you
next episode
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]